so very well so this is what I will talk
about and let me tell you a little bit
about myself so I did PhD at the Hebrew
University and I was a postdoc at
Carnegie Mellon University where we
started to work on a graph lab open
source project and after about four
years of project once the project became
more popular we opened the company which
is based in Seattle and we have also a
small office in Israel where I'm based
so this is data as I said we're based in
Seattle we have around 50 people we have
a strong research team of around 13 PhDs
and today I'll tell you a little bit
about predictive applications and how we
implement them using ruffler create so a
bit of a motivation one motivation slide
is that we are talking about what the
cool what are the cool things we can do
in machine learning and a few years ago
it was enough for a company just to have
a database and store all the information
in a database but then later not only
database queries gain inside but you
have also all kinds of reporting tools
but today it's not enough to have just
some kind of report it's more
interesting to have a predictive
application that learns about your data
make predictions and try to decide what
will happen a tomorrow so that's the
area where we focus on and we have a lot
of type of applications and I'll show
you today many of them and some examples
are recommenders fraud and detection
which is a cyber-related a targeting and
so on so when we talk about data science
we have a kind of a green upon a
pipeline which typically you start from
some data set you take it you ingest it
you have to clean it a little bit make
some transformation and then you want to
build a model and eventually you would
like to deploy the model for customer
for making the predictions of our online
scoring of the model so this is the way
it's typically done and we handle all
those areas of activity
and yesterday when I looked around and
just outside this room I found this nice
commercial to one of the companies here
which says that a scientist is the
sexiest job of the 21st company of the
21st century which I agree it's a lot of
fun to hear we do a lot of sexy things
and it's very popular and they are
talking about big data in machine
learning and neuro bias night work
whatever they are have no clue and
decision automation and scoring and so
on so those fits very nicely into our
model of having being able to capably
handle the data building models and
making some scoring on top of those
models so everything I agree here so i
would like to steal this commercial also
to what we do but if we focus a little
bit about the actual modeling on its own
so we usually start with some data then
we would like to take a look of the data
explore it a little bit and then milled
some models and this is an iterative
procedure because you basically once you
build the model the model quality may
not be that great and you may need to
grip to bring a grab more data and then
build the better models and so on so
that's an iterative cycle and on this
cycle i we focus on a two-day stock and
i want to show you some examples about
intelligent applications what we call
that are starting and originating from
data so there are different types of
data sets we are working on things like
images text graphs and tabular data and
i'll show you examples of all of them
today we also handle time series but i
want focus on that today so we are
starting from the data and as you recall
a machine learning that science is the
sexiest job ever so i wanted to start
with some concrete examples of customer
projects that we worked on and one of
the most bizarre i would say projects is
given
this image so anyone can guess what with
the inside so no one has a clue I will
tell you and this is a company called
Kampala G in the US which puts cameras
inside trash bins and in this image the
camera was mistakenly directed to the
other side so you see someone was trying
to grab something out of the trash bin
and so it was accidentally captured in
this image so this is kind of the weird
things that companies are really doing
so when you asked me about cameras in
trance twins it sounds a bit crazy but
it actually happened so that's a real
project and the goal was to find a
detector how much trash there is inside
in order to optimize the truck routes
that go and pick up those trash bins so
that's one weird thing we've seen the
second project we were kind of involved
was a face detection and this is example
of some of the images we got from a
company that does a homeland security
type of monitoring of people who enter
secure facilities and as you can see
they have a slight problem with lighting
and so we got some images but basically
you can see anything and they said ok we
will hire data scientist and he will
find an algorithm to find who are those
persons but basically as you may imagine
it's not working like that if you have
crappy inputs nothing you can do the
most fancy neural network won't be dead
sufficient to understand what's going on
and that's really crappy data set and my
advice was you should put a light in
front in front of the camera and it will
be much better believe me it will be
much easier task and you need less a few
data scientists so let me show you
another project so you may say images
are difficult we know we want to try
maybe do some text analytics they
is easy so we got this company who told
us you we have really easy task you just
have to tell us this is the drug
prescription a real passion I just
removed all the identifying details and
here the goal was to find a medication
named the medication dose how many times
it's given a day and with the patient
and as you can see i try to read this i
can't read anything i don't know how a
data scientist Quinn solve this because
this doctor handwriting is horrible so
that was a difficult task we actually
prefer not to to take especially if you
know a text analytics there are problem
with the alignment of the page and so on
and this some problems are not that easy
while the job is the kind of sexy steel
and they are challenging a items so we
talked a little about text and usually
when I give a talk I don't like to show
too many slides because it's kind of
boring so i want to show you more
interactive demos of thing we do which I
find way more interesting so i would
like to start with the demo i have here
about mexican restaurants in San
Francisco using test text review so i
hope you can see the font so what we're
doing here we are trying to understand
based on user reviews and what they are
saying and what are their sentiment
about the restaurant so typically when i
say fat fat is a bad keyword the food
was fat it was not good and so on so
typically I would say in my connotation
at least it's kind of a bad keyword but
the way we do hear it here is actually
we take into account the whole context
of the sentence and not just the single
keyboard so what I'm doing here I'm
querying for all the Mexican restaurants
that have enough reviews that mentioned
the word fat and as you can see there
are different scores or some restaurants
the fat is more positive in some of them
the fat is more negative so I can dive
in into a specific restaurant which is
Tommy restaurant
and here and I can try and show you
what's going on inside the review so i
don't know if you can read these texts
because probably the projector is i hope
you can read it but basically so the
first ten students i'm going to
completely skip because we're yeah well
when you read the what customers are
actually generating and everything here
is real data by the way so this the
first time send this is performing crazy
guy i will skip but the second a
sentence i like so i always get the
combination plates because I'm fat and I
like to eat and this is a good place so
that's a good review and here there is a
very long review but it tells you I
restaurant was kind of nice and i gave
fat tips though I was happy so that was
a fat in a good connotation and then I'm
another review which ends with Viva
Tommy so that's good review and also
they have a fat aquila selection which
is kind of a good from the other hand
and if you are into lousy food and faced
with us you should go for this play
that's very negative and we identify it
nicely and here another one which I like
is the room was so crowded to the point
that if we want we could have given our
neighbors a fat lip or black eye so
that's a imaginative use of words and
also the place sucks a big fat one and I
wish I can give the big fat and so on so
those are very negative reviews with the
world of fat so this is kind of a cool
application with the text and I want to
show you a little more of the things we
do also with other things so we do
handle a images so we do things like
image similarities and not this one
sorry I want to show em this one so we
do things like image similarities or
given a certain trace and I like floral
dresses the dress is sent to the
predictive server and then we identify
in the store all the dresses in floral
patterns so actually this is based on
the image properties
on the keywords which appear in the
image and as you can see it's very nice
selection of a races with floral
patterns so this is another application
which is more in a fashion and let me
show one last one quickly which is
related to a mmm sorry not this one to
recommenders so this is an application
where I can it's based on Amazon data I
like a certain movie I like Jim Carrey
stupid movies so the queries sent to the
server and then I get all the learn
movies that go together so you know that
if you like stupid movies Jim Carrey and
so on so if you like rocky for Rocky 5
and so on they're all stupid movies and
your kind of stupid more or less like me
from the other end whenever I want to
see a movie with my wife she is way more
serious she likes drama she likes Jane
Austen she likes Sense and Sensibility
it's a drama movie and we can do some
graph analytics in order to find the
relation between us and then let me tell
you how she convinced me to view the
crap she likes so basically she tells me
oh you like Dumb and Dumber so that with
Adam Gilmore so you see another movie
with oblem Gilmore and then if you like
it you should see the wedding singer
which is with Adam feel more but it's
kind of romantic comedy and if you like
it you will see clueless which is also
romantically the comedy but it's also
parody of Emma so many of the people
that watch clueless than a day later
watch Emma so that's kind of nice and if
you like em iu likes and since its
ability because there are two novels by
Jane Austen so this is the way to
convince me although some people when I
say it when I lecture they say you're
lying your wife just telling you what to
see which is always correct but if this
I can try to have a nice story around
how she convinces me so that's another
kind of application cool things you can
do with recommenders and since we out by
in PI data I want to show you actual
code and how I run it so it will be more
interesting than
showing demos which are user facing so
i'm going to show you and about two
months ago I was in PI data mr. damn
which was really nice and there I gave
the the crowd the listeners I gave them
the possibility of hearing one of two
things either web session log demo or
recommender demo and everyone we wanted
to have the recommender demo so I had to
give the recommender demo now I'm much
smarter so I'm not going to give you any
options and i'm going to show you the
web session logs demo and the reason
that i'm going to show you the web
session log demo is that so far you said
although all those crappy companies are
in the US we know everyone crazy in the
US but i have a web session demo with
the data set from germany so i'm sure
you will like it and by the way it's
real data set so i'm not going to give
it 21 but and soon you will see why so
here i'm jumping a to our programming
interface which is in python as i
promised and this is a ipython notebook
which is a very cool project we like and
the first thing i'm doing i'm importing
GraphLab we are a python-based package
and we have pip install and we have also
other types of installer the second
thing i'm loading a data with the web
session information so like in pandas we
have a data frame but the difference is
that our data frame is way more scalable
it's called scalable data frame that's
why and they because it works from disk
so we don't load that a fully into
memory but we read it in chat from disk
so as you can see our data has 350
thousand rows that's very small data set
we can of course scale too much larger
but it's a kind of a fun toy data set to
show you some quick inside and using my
laptop so the first thing I'm going to
do is to show you the tabular data said
like in pandas so we have things that I
like the user ID what was the day at the
time the country and as you see
surprised I wasn't lying the countries
Germany and people do decent activities
at work like going to
banking portal and star games and things
and this data set okay so that's a real
a data set I've only anonymized the IP
okay just not to reveal anyone here so
the first thing I want to do is you
remember we said we have some data
exploration that we like to do so we
start a we do that a show on our canvas
and we can see different properties of
the data so we can see the data is only
in one date and so on in a few time
beans and everyone almost is from
Germany don't know if you can see this
color but I can convince you so
basically it's a German data set and we
have also the ability to view it as a
tabular data structure like Excel but
the main difference is that you can jump
to any row and see what's inside and we
have some plotting capabilities that you
can quickly a plot correlations and so
on and get insights what's getting on
your deaths so let's go back to the
program and the next thing I can do we
can do all kinds of ETL types a
transformation that you need in order to
clean your data so the first thing I'm
doing I would like to create a new
column that will be a concatenation of
the date and time columns which are both
strings and then I would like to apply
some conversion in order to get a date
time data structure what's interesting
about this call it's like pandas the
same syntax of apply lambda function
where the difference is that we paralyze
it on all course so it's of that single
machine and so it's more efficient and
then we have the same tabular data
structure but we have generated a new
column which is a date time column the
next thing I can show you is that we
have a lot of SQL type aggregation like
in pandas so you can do things like a
select join and group by so here I want
to account the unique user per country
so i can grow by by country and your uid
and then concatenate another group by
for counting the countries and then I
have for cutting the unique user per
country and then I have for each country
how many unique users and as I prom with
this is a German data set so we have six
thousand users from Germany in this data
see the next thing I would like to show
you is how we run analytics and we have
a lot of capabilities so one of them
that I briefly mentioned is graph
analytics so it's very easy you just
create an empty graph and then you add
the edges so when you add the edges and
to this graph i'm running a graph based
algorithm on top of this graph so I'm
preparing a graph and then I'm running
connected components which will tell me
what of the areas of activities on this
Web sessions whether everyone is doing
the same activity or maybe there are
separate types of activities like
fashion and sports and politics and so
on so I'm running it now strangely it's
bit slow that's they're always the risk
of online demos so let's see
yeah so now it's finished so as you can
see we got we got some results and the
next thing we can do we can actually
count how many nodes are in each
component so that's the result of this
algorithm and here we can see there is
one really large component which has
22,000 nodes so this is a BLT draft by
by the way so the users are connected
the website is served in and then we
want to see whether there are different
types of activities so we can see there
everyone in Germany is serving more or
less to the same a website and there are
some disjoint activities on the side
which are kind of small so let me show
you what we can further do in this
analytics so I'm just picking up the
largest component ID which is this
number and then I would like to join the
data back into the web sessions so why
this is useful when I have web sessions
they have certain properties and now i'm
running graph analytics getting inside
to which component this this belongs to
and then I'm putting the results back
into the same double or data structure
and now we'll have another feature that
we will be the component ID so in that
case I can know and so this is a
different additional column in my data
set that tells me this is a type of
activity this guy was doing using the
graph analytics so that's the component
idea the next thing I can do I can dive
into this component to see what's going
on inside so I can run for example page
rank so it's very easy to concatenate
algorithms so I can run a graph
analytics run page rank on the largest
component so this is the pandas type
selection that I'm just selecting all
the rows which confirm to the last large
component then I'm adding edges and then
I'm getting the results so let me show
you the results as you may expect it the
most popular websites in Germany our
google youtube facebook and so on ebay
and amazon so nothing surprising here
but if we look at
list or wast websites the websites with
the lowest page rank in Germany so we
have drunken mature tube porn sex so
young teens poker and manga so those are
the worst websites according to the page
rank and here we've got to start to see
a lot of interesting activities of what
users are doing so the next thing I can
show you really briefly and I want to go
into the sec's website so I'm going to
the gaming websites to spare you but we
can it's very easy to plot those results
so let me plot it in a second and I can
show you so those are the results and
this is people the purple dots are the
eyepiece and this is the kind of games
they played and if they are let's say if
it if it is data capture from work you
may say okay this guy is not working I
mean this guy played one game it work
it's fine but this guy played ten
different games at work and probably we
should fire him immediately so that's
the kind of a cool analytics you can do
in web blogs so I'll jump a bit and let
me jump today how gruff love is they
built what's the platform about now that
we've seen some applications so we have
an open source engine so we love open
source and it's called s frame on github
and it's bsd license and anyone can play
with it and change it as needed and so
on and on top of it we have a part of it
we have efficient data structures that
allow you to run analytics very
efficiently on top of the engine so we
have different types of data structure
for tabular data structure for graph
type analytics and also for time series
analytics a wave also an SDK in c++ that
you can I guess this is by some
conference and shouldn't say that but
the major interface is of course in
Python and we
have a lot of machine learning tool kits
on top of the engine which are
python-based as I showed you and and we
have visualization our product does
require a license but it is free for
academic usage so anyone with a student
or participating in Cabul competition
can get a free license besides of our
modeling capabilities we have also a
predictive server that you can serve the
models and all the examples that I've
shown you are running in a predictive
server that run in US Coast in Amazon
where I actually submit a query using
restful api and then i get quickly the
response with the recommendations or the
related images and so on we also run a
on top of different type of
infrastructure so we have also
distributed version but I won't get into
too much details here due to lack of
time so i want to discuss a little bit
about some differences to psychic
learning some performance and why
actually use us so in terms of disk
representation we have way more
compressed representation versus pandas
so it because it is more compressed we
need to read less from disk and then
practically when you work in RAM you
have a speed up which is not that bad
when you work from disk so it's about
two times slower and flash drive versus
running everything in memory and it's
about five times slower in this but
still we can scale as big as that this
can get so here is the one comparison
slide two scikit-learn this is a linear
regression task and we have it the
benchmark is fully available on the web
anyone can try it out and hear what you
see is basically a the runtime should be
as low as possible so the blue line is
almost flat and it's about 50 times
faster than scikit-learn but m we also a
circular dies at some point because it
runs out of memory and we continue
running from disk so this curve
continues
a long way and you can scale to much
larger data sets some other differences
they related to scikit-learn are related
to the multi-core support so all of our
algorithms they are fully multi-core
paralyzed and not a single threaded we
work from this case I mentioned we do a
lot of automatic feature expansion which
is missing in secular so we do a lot of
things to help you get quickly to your
results without creating features
translating two categorical stupid
binary and so on and a lot of a
workaround automatic parameter selection
we do trial on a subset of the data set
in order to give you good parameters to
start with and we have also the serving
capabilities and the support for many
algorithms that are missing inside learn
like deep learning text algorithm
sentiment and churn prediction many
things that are missing mmm I will maybe
show one more two more plots and
regarding performance that made me
relevant so if you're using spark we
have a conectar tu pais park so it's
very easy to use our tools and basically
we are way faster so you'll need way
more machines in spark in order to do
the same task that you can do with us
without a cluster so a lot of users
which are data scientists and
statisticians they prefer to avoid the
need of actually using a cluster when
you don't really have to we are a
commercial company so we do have a lot
of customers so this is a one bragging
slide about the different type of use
cases we see and have shown a few of
them and one last thing that I want to
add to show is that we actually have a
free call seller course and that you can
take it's very popular we have around
10,000 additional students every month
and it's held jointly with university of
washington and carlos gastrin is our CEO
is a professor at university of
washington so anyone wants to learn more
about that the scientist is welcome to
take those courses and I have here some
brochures if you like to have the course
address and here i would like to
finalize so basically our mission is to
create sexy data science and this is my
email and i'll be be happy to talk to
anyone here is interested in
brainstorming about your problems and we
would love to help so I will yes so the
question was do we handle sparse data so
we have tools to handle sparse and dense
data our tableau data structure s frame
you can put inside in each column you
can have a dictionary or a space vector
and we also support graph analytics for
if you need things like sparse matrices
and graphs so yes we do handle less per
state
you